now more than a year after the pandemic
we're still learning about who
is most at risk for the coronavirus in
today's health watch
denise valdez is here in the studio
joining us live with an alarming friend
well christian research shows that
obesity dramatically
increases the risk for severe covid19
illness in fact
a cdc study of more than 70 thousand
hospitalized coping patients from
actually finds more than half of them 51
percent were obese
28 percent were overweight so experts
are really convinced that people who are
obese and get copic 19
will have much worse outcomes doctors
treating cobit patients say at least one
of four conditions
obesity hypertension diabetes or heart
failure
was responsible for the majority of
hospitalizations
this is across the country with obesity
being the top risk
cova 19 is like you're pouring gasoline
on a fire
when you have those underlying
conditions because it attacks not only
the lungs
but attacks the blood vessels and it
causes inflammation throughout the body
dr mozafarian is a cardiologist and
hopes that more people just get the
message that maintaining a healthy
weight
can be a lifesaver obesity can also
affect the immune system which can make
people more vulnerable to infections
and also make it tougher for them to
fight off an infection
in fact it is estimated that 42 percent
of adults in this country
are obese in fact many states now are
starting to prioritize patients with
obesity
to receive the covid19 vaccine because
they're at such high risk
but some doctors are frustrated that as
much as the government keeps telling us
that we've got to wash our hands with
our social distance
there should also be an emphasis on
eating well and maintaining a healthy
weight